,
le ciel, qui est quelque part
dans les scènes, lui envoie
une pluie de timbres-prime qui
l'inonde...
- André Brassard se passionne
pour le théâtre depuis qu'il est
enfant. Et il vient d'avoir
22 ans quand, en 1968,
Les Belles-soeurs révolution
le théâtre québécois.
Avec l'auteur Michel Tremblay,
il veut mettre en scène
un milieu qu'il connait,
et comme il l'entend.
- (en choeur): moé, j'aime ça
le bingo!
- Je pense qu'il faut le faire
en joual. Ce serait malhonnête
de le faire autrement, parce
qu'il y a rien que je ne trouve
autant outrageant qu'un plombier
dans une pièce qui dit toi et
moi.
- La collaboration des deux
hommes s'étendra sur près de 40
ans.
Brassard fera la mise enceinte
de presque toutes les pièces de
Tremblay. Il travaille aussi
avec d'autres auteurs.
Le metteur en scène est reconnu
pour son extraordinaire
compréhension du texte.
- Il réalisera aussi quatre
films.
Ce film représente le Canada au
Festival de Cannes.
En 1982, il accepte la direc
artistique du théâtre français
du centre national des arts à
Ottawa.
Après huit années dans ce poste,
il quitte la capitale
canadienne, désabusé par le
manque de soutien à ces projets.
De retour à Montréal, ils
forment ensuite toute une
génération de comédiens à la
École nationale de théâtre.
Parfois aussi, il se met en
scène comme ici au côté de son
interprète fétiche, Rita
Lafontaine, dans "encore une
fois si vous le permettez".
En 1999,1 accident vasculaire
cérébral le laisse amoindrie
physiquement. Mais sa vivacité
d'esprit demeure comme letravai.
Les années suivantes,
André Brassard fait de sa
biographie une sorte de
testament. Il y parle
ouvertement de ses excès passés,
de sa consommation de drogue et
de sa condamnation pour
détournement dominant. Au
lancement, il en profitera pour
saluer ceux avec qui il a
partagé sa passion pour le
théâtre.
- Merci Paul ouverture d'esprit,
merci de